the alarm goes off please leave the
building in an orderly fashion through
the nearest fire exit
please use either fire exit through the
main doors of the Hall of the fire exit
into the storeroom adjacent to the stage
the fire assembly point is in the island
at the front of the main entrance to the
building please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff
please note that the meeting is audio
recorded
please switch off mobiles or turn them
to silent
please note that toilet and hand washing
facilities are in the foyer area
members of the public while you are of
course entitled to film or take
photographs during this meeting can I
please emphasize to you that this should
be done without disruption to the
meeting and can only be done from a
designated area in the public seating
thank you very much for raising your
hand clearly in the air and that you are
photographing and filming this evening I
will now ask officers to assist sorry I
don't need to say that because you're
already sitting thank you so members
please be outstanding to receive the
chairman Reverend Kim lepley and the
chief executive
good evening members
welcome
I'll hand over to Reverend Kim to get
the praise
so let us pray
almighty God we bring before you this
evening the agenda for this meeting
that we who have been entrusted with the
responsibility to govern and make
decisions for those who have elected us
that we would be guided by the best of
motives and with the interests of all
for the benefit of all
give clear Minds to our counselors and
the desire to hear all points of view
including those that may be
diametrically opposed to our own
for an openness of debate
make us gracious and courteous to friend
an opponent alike with a real sense of
working together for this district and
the areas that are represented by each
of our district councilors
at the same time we commend for your
blessing the work of all the employees
of Rochford District Council who
maintain Implement and make possible the
words that are debated discussed and
formed into policy and decisions
I'm going to pray the Lord's Prayer and
if you would like to join in with this
prayer then please feel free to do so
Our Father which art in heaven Hallowed
be thy name thy kingdom come thy will be
done in earth as it is in heaven give us
this day our daily bread and forgive us
our trespasses as we forgive them that
trespass against us and lead us not into
temptation but Deliver Us from Evil for
thine is the kingdom the power and the
glory forever and ever amen
I'll now hand over to your chief
executive
relatively short period of time um
unfortunately lost this fight against
pancreatic cancer last week on behalf of
all members and officers would be nice
to hold silence
Heavenly Father we pray for colleagues
friends and family of Ian Winslet we
hold them before you and pray that they
would know your peace
amen
the final blessing for you all this
evening
the blessing of God Almighty the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit be with you
and all whom you love this evening and
forevermore amen
I'd like to take this opportunity of
thanking you for your service but also
wishing you a very merry Christmas
hopefully it's not too busy for you as
you lead up to that time but I do wish
you a wonderful happy Christmas and New
Year God bless you thank you thank you
you're welcome to stay as always yeah I
might be able to tempt you because
thank you very much I wish you well
thank you members please be seated
foreign
[Music]
you to speak
please wait until there is a microphone
in front of you
before speaking
as the microphones are needed for the
hearing Loop and the audio recording
they are all switched on ready for you
to speak so you do not need to adjust
them
please make sure
is the hearing loophole just to make
absolutely certain
yes
okay is that better can you hear
okay
this is the important bit please make
sure the microphone is directly in front
of you
should have done that bit first
shouldn't I really
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution
I will ask for a show of hands then
four and then against
the recommendations and then for
abstaining
given the size of this room and the
number of us present
can I please ask that you put your hand
up clearly
as I've always said like when you were
at school
high in the air so we can be easily seen
by all and leave it up until I ask you
to lower it or the vice geminosity Club
members we'll go straight into agenda
item one
apologies for absence I have I have here
apologies from counselor butcher Myers
Squires Coleman
um
Gladstone and
Foster
is there any others that have not been
listed
councilamil
can't hear you councilman
June Lumley is not okay lovely we can
make a note to that please
I agenda item two
minutes of the meeting held on October
the 25th 2022
members are you happy for me to sign the
minutes of the meeting
held on the 25th of October is that
agreed by members great chairman
thank you
gender item three Declarations of
Interest are that any Declarations of
Interest
I remind you members if anything should
come up during the course of the debate
please make it clear at that point and
we will make a note of
right agenda item four announcement
that's from the chairman leader
and head of paid service
members since our last four council
meeting Christmas is in full swing and I
hope you will join me for a drink
afterwards upstairs
November was very busy with visits to
many local businesses and I was
privileged to represent Rochford
District in Barling Saturn Rochford for
their remembrance services
in November I also visit the music block
opening at the king Edmond School
which was absolutely amazing
to see what they have done
that
it was before the disappointing that
shortly afterwards we had to Temporary
close the school
because I think most members are aware
of the issues with asbestos
and I'm very impressed that the council
Rockford Council has stepped in
providing space at The Freight House in
a very short space of time so my
compliments to the staff for doing that
it's been beginning to feel a lot like
Christmas and I'm not going to sing
I've enjoyed tending the local Parish
Christmas lights switch-ons
which are all wonderfully successful and
well attended
the elves cabin by Rochford teenage
Market was the first held here in the
Mill Hall Mill arts and events center
and sponsored by Roxford District
Council offering young people a free
platform to Showcase their talents
and they really do have so many talented
people
attended Carol services from around
Essex
to add to the Christmas feeling and with
the snow
and I must point out in parliam we
didn't get any everybody else got it
they missed us
to settle in places
and I hope we don't get too much more
now
lastly my Civic Carol service is taking
place this Friday
I said Andrew's Church in Rochford
that's best by the golf club
and I hope to see as many of you there
as possible
thank you
councilor Wootton have you any
announcements
yes please if I may chairman thank you
with your permission I would like to
make a statement on dampen mold on
properties within the rochwood district
like all of us here tonight I was
shocked and saddened to hear of the
tragic death of young awab ISAC as a
result of damper mold conditions in his
home
I welcome the resultant focus on damper
mold issues from the government and
social housing regulator that this has
prompted I hope this will result in a
positive response from the social
housing sector
our aim in Rochford is for everybody to
live healthy safe and fulfilling lives
this includes access to safe and warm
homes
since the inquest findings into awab's
death were made public Rochford Council
has acted promptly to ensure that
landlords across the district are
meeting their legal obligations taking
proactive action to support residents
and preventing or eradicating damp and
mold wherever possible
the Secretary of State for leveling up
housing and communities wrote to all
local authorities on the 19th of
November requesting information on
private sector damper mold reports and
details of how councils are prioritizing
actions on damper malt the target for an
initial response was the 30th of
November with a full response by the
27th of January 2023
I'm pleased to say that Rochford was
able to supply the response in full by
the end of November
the council's enforcement service
investigates all complaints of disrepair
in the private rented sector including
damper mold
the enforcement service dealt with 19
reported damp and mold cases within the
last three years
all cases were resolved through either
advice or service of notice on the
landlord
the council is not needed to issue civil
penalties or prosecutions against any
landlord during that period
Brookshire Council does not own any of
its social housing nationally all
registered providers housing
associations have been contacted by the
regulator of social housing and asked to
provide data about dampened mold
prevalence within their stock
Additionally the council has contacted
all registered providers operating
within the district
they have been asked for information on
all dampened mold cases and how these
have been dealt with
plus how they will be prioritizing dump
and mold cases in Watford homes
I am pleased to say that we've had a
positive response from a number of
providers including Sanctuary housing
our largest landlord
all have stressed their commitment to
improving outcomes for residents
ensuring all all damper mold cases are
prioritized and monitored at a senior
level within their organizations
finally I would like to point out the
support of council the council offers to
Residents in rented homes
this includes a dedicated page on the
council's website information resources
on how to report or tackle damp mold and
condensation
how to rent videos for new tenants are
ready to rent inspection service for
landlords and how to apply for the
council's affordable warmth program
as a council we will continue to
investigate and Tackle all complaints of
damper mold
we will work with registered provider
Partners to hold them to account where
required to share data and best practice
making a positive difference to the
residents of the Roxford District
thank you chairman thank you
Mr Stevenson do you have any
announcements you wish to make thank you
chairman I have no announcements to meet
this evening thank you thank you
members agenda item five to note the
minutes of the executive and committee
meetings held between the period 15th of
October to the 30th of November 2022
are these noted members
kill
gender item six business from last
council meeting
members does anyone have any questions
relating to the business from the
council meeting held on the 25th of
October
okay thank you
General item seven
reports on the Urgent decisions there
are none
agenda item eight
harmonization of pay terms and
conditions
for the one team partnership and this is
in the hands of the chief executive
executive Mr Stevenson
thank you chairman members you have a
report in front of you item eight um
this report around the harmonization of
paying terms and conditions for the one
team partnership this has been brought
about since the agreement on the 25th of
January of
2022 where we agreed to have a strategic
partnership with brentwoods as part of
that journey tonight sets out the
framework for pay and remuneration for
any members of staff that take on a role
across the partnership I'm more than
happy to take any questions on on
tonight's on the report tonight
thank you
are there any questions
council Mrs Wilson
hello thank you Mrs Wilson can I remind
you to stand oh
we're just chairman
um yeah I just had two questions
um and that's probably because I'm
fairly new at this and I might have
missed some information from earlier
but um I've read in the papers that the
review will start at the end of 2022
which is great I just wondered is there
um unexpected to be completed date
obviously this might move but is there
is there an end date
in mind and my second question chair is
um who has undertaking this review and
our members involved in this thank you
thank you chairman and thank you
councilor Wilson Mrs Wilson
um with regard to the reviews there'll
be a number of reviews throughout the
partnership um sort of due diligence
work across different Services the
intention is any service of a
certificate to change because coming
together these will come in front of
members for a number of different forums
in particular as a group back in January
25th to go to overview and scrutiny
ahead of going to the relevant committee
that could either be executive or
Council so that's the intention
council Mrs Mason
it's like to have some reassurance
because when we have these situations it
creates I'm sure uncertainty for our
staff
and
I notice there's quite a degree of
variation between the conditions
between the two councils
can I ask if the intention I hope it is
is that for existing staff
should the
outcome on a particular item be less
than what their present contract is that
their terms will remain on the most
beneficial if they're already in service
in other words will the staff not lose
out through this process
thank you
thank you chairman um thank you
councilor Mrs Mason with regard to the
appendix B that looks at both the
Brentwood exam conditions and the
Rochford terms conditions the intention
is that no one loses out and and
betterment where there is an opportunity
around that for some areas so as you can
see there's a number of areas holiday
allowances are different at Brentwood to
Rochford so the intention would be to
get on the higher level of holiday
allowance for the partnership so no one
will lose out if they're going for a
similar role across across the
Partnerships if that was the case
um we will still have our own terms and
conditions and pay within Rochford and
brimwood and this is the one team
framework so the intention will be to
services that come jointly we'll use the
framework any services that stay within
Rochford or Brentwood or use the current
pay mechanisms that we currently got in
place
hope that answers your question
uh thank you yes it does it remain
reassured thank you
anyone else
Mrs Wilson council Mrs Wilson did you
um
get your two questions in
sorry Chad didn't quite hear you did you
get your two questions
that you managed to do
I'd just like to clarify the my point
about an end date
if I may thank you
thank you chairman and thank you Council
Mr Wilson yes so with regard to the
actual service reviews
um we're looking at the reviews over the
next um 12 to 18 months so those reviews
will be so the intention will be that
um we're moving at relatively Swift Pace
because obviously uh mentioned about
uncertainty uh with staff so actually
it's good to rather than hanging out for
a long period of time but the first
service reviews have started
um they'll they'll come to a conclusion
then they'll come in front of members of
the significant changes and being
proposed so by the end of next year the
majority of those service reviews will
have hopefully been done with regard to
the partnership they're making mention
is that once we've done though you might
have to look at
um sort of looking at some of those
Services again because we do them
individually but looking at it as a
broader corporate effects we may have to
look at where some Services might need
some some reviews again but unlikely
that is the case but there may be some
service where we see some benefits of
once we've done one service we then look
at another sources actually would it be
helpful to try and combine those two
Services moving forward in some areas so
just to reassure you
um today was the second of two physical
staff briefings that have been across
Brentwood and Rochford we have a number
of communications for staff but um today
we had nearly 100 people at The Freight
House for a staff briefing and a number
of questions were answered and today's
tonight's report has been presented was
also discussed to reassure um staff
where there was some sort of uncertainty
or anxiety around sort of some of the
changes but hopefully the number of
questions proposed and answered but
that's made the workforce even more
reassured even though like any change
there is some uncertainty for people who
are reassured that have had those
questions asked answered
okay
Council Newport
thank you chairman
um I'm afraid my colleague to my left
here
um cannot hear anything that Mr
Stevenson just said
um could we
maybe adjust the audio somewhat thank
you
can you uh arrange it
okay I think he adjusts the difference
on the microphone okay okay would you
want me to repeat yeah please if you
would
hmm
can you hear me now what's up
I don't know okay to cover that question
is that uh for Council standing you can
hear me now okay no problem I think
rather than bow down I'll hold the
microphone if everybody's happy with
that so with regard to the service
reviews the service reviews will look to
intend to be um completed by the end of
next year
um subject to work at a swift Pace but
also making sure we do far due diligence
on all the service views they will come
in front of members if the significant
change has been proposed for overview
and scrutiny and then through to
Executive or Council depending on the
function and requirement for that what I
did mention also we did a number of
Staff briefings over the last two weeks
um to ensure that staff had an
opportunity to engage physically with
all of the management team around any
questions they might have especially
knowing a report like this was coming
this evening as well so today we
concluded those staff briefings one of
the last one being at The Freight House
of over 100 staff attended and a number
of questions were answered hopefully
that helps thank you sorry about that
okay you you may skate all that kind of
standing
okay any other questions
okay members
there are two recommendations in
paragraph 14.2 on the report on page 8.4
I'll read them out
first recommendation uh that the
proposed one team scales are set out in
appendix a are be approved subject to
the final regulation negotiation with
unison
two that the proposed one team terms and
conditions are set out in appendix B
be approved
subject to the final negotiations with
unison
members are you happy that I take those
both together
members
I'll move those from the chair
members those in favor
council Mrs Rose sorry
and we have a look that's what I have on
this sheet here
okay member sorry that wasn't on my
sheet I do apologize for that
okay I'll read out 14.1
to ensure that there is a single unified
pay structure as well as
terms and conditions to create
parity across the this Council and
Brentwood Borough Council
this would also ensure we remain
competitive with the local government
sector minimizing Recruitment and
Retention challenges we are all facing
within the sector
okay
members are you still happy for me to
take those all as one item
okay
pausing hey somebody puts their head up
okay members those in favor
please signify
okay
thank you
yeah Mr McPherson uh Council McPherson
seconds then
so those in favor
okay
members that is unanimous
members a general
agenda item nine allocations of seats on
committees
the report will
be introduced by the councilors interim
director of people and governments
Andrew Hunkin
thank you chairman you have a report in
front of you on the allocation of seats
too good
the allocation of seats to committees
um there's also there's also been the
opportunity to change the number of
seats on the planning policy committee
from six to seven
with this report you also have an
addendum which sets out the various
counselors names against the seats so
you should all have those in front of
you and that in essence is a report
thank you chairman thank you
members we have one recommendation at
this particular point
are there any questions
no
the recommendation at this point and I
moved from the chair is that the council
committees be constituted as set out in
appendix one to this report do I have a
second please
councilor Wilkinson
thank you chair
um forgive me if I've misunderstood you
there are a couple of the the Committees
that have been over nominated which we
need to discuss yes that will come as a
next item let's party we need to do this
bit first all right so were you second
to mine no okay
I need a second before you move
thank you Council wood
okay members those in favor of the
recommendation I've just read out
pre-signify
that was that unanimous the kid
members you will see that the group
leaders have nominated
to 10 out of the 11 13 seats on the
development committee program committee
and these names are listed on the bottom
of page
9.10
in addition group leaders have nominated
four members to the three remaining
seats to determine
to determine these nominations I will
call out each member's name in turn
and ask for a show of hands for each
member
the three members with the most votes
will be appointed to the seats
they're very happy with that clear with
that
councilor Mrs Shaw
on the top the four members
okay sorry to be the damn tick but just
want to make sure we know what we're
voting on thank you sorry my sheet says
why point in but
thank you
okay
okay is everybody clear on the voting
but he's happy with that right okay
the first name that I will read out
is Art counselor
Eileen gladson can I have a show of fans
whatever your hands
next one is counselor Jack Lawman
but I still do not understand how we can
vote more than once
I would just like some clarification
Jessica we'll just get some clerical
occasionally
foreign
chairman there's an elimination process
here in in that you have more candidates
and seats here obviously you need to be
filling uh those vacant seats which is
why the seats will go to the number of
to the accounters with the most votes
and you are able to vote for for each
candidate on the on the paper here
thank you
so I can't hear you councilor away so
before clarification we have four votes
each that's correct
that's
only four one there's four full votes
next four votes
four people
votes
um
no it's four four people
members please bear with me but I just
had another query to that which has been
provided by one of my group members is
that if we have four votes each does
that mean we can vote four times for a
single candidate thank you
no I don't think that's quite right
so you have uh there are four candidates
here for three three positions so you
will be asked to raise your hand if
you're in favor of each candidate as
they read out so you can have four votes
on that and it will then just be the
number of uh the three councilors with
the most votes who will then be
allocated to the seats
can we clarify we have three votes each
four votes you just said we had three
vote you said you couldn't have four
votes are really confused now
can we vote for four candidates yes we
can yes
four times yeah
each each person I read out
you have a vote in either agreeing to
that person being on the side taking a
seat or not
so by putting your hand up you are
agreeing that that person goes forward
possibly let's see
council Mrs Belton
sorry I don't mean to be pedantic but
I'm sure we only get three votes here
because there's three vacancies and
we've done this before
members if you'd like to let's talk
about yourselves for a moment
um I'll just talked to the monitor
officer on this
um Council Ahoy thank you just for a
moment thank you
members if I can have your attention
again please
okay with a bit of a debate and a quick
check through the Constitution there
uh thank you for bringing it to
attention to counselor hoy
each member has three votes
and they can use that though those votes
for any one of the four names that we I
will read out
okay
so we've already done the first one
second one
you want me to do again okay
okay first one is councilor Eileen
Gladstone
okay
particular hands
second one is counselor Jack Lawman
okay thank you members lay your hands
third one is counselor Chris Stanley
and the fourth one is counselor Stuart
Wilson
okay put your hands right up so we can
see them folks
okay if I could have the numbers please
foreign
16.
councilor Lawman eight
councilor Stanley 9.
councilor Wilson 23.
so
the vote goes to the three highest
so that's Mrs councilor Mrs glsen
councilor Stanley
and councilor Wilson
members we have received eight
nominations to the nine seats of the
chief executives
officer's appointments committee
are there any further Nim reckon any
further nominations
to the one outstanding seat
no one
okay
okay
members that will then just remain
vacant
councilor Mrs Rowe
[Music]
thank you chairman um that to me seems
pointless now the conservatives as
they've got a position on development
cannot put anyone else forward
on the chief officer's appointment
committee so can I suggest that The
Independents do
is anybody want to put their hand up
it's a difficult sale this isn't it
counselor Mrs Mason
um can I ask for some clarification from
our officers
we we have a vacancy on a committee most
committees are normally Paratha
however it's not being filled under the
Paratha rules therefore can we can that
position be filled by any member from
any group or does it have to be under
the Paratha rules thank you okay I'll
get some clarification on that in a
second uh councilor
Wilkinson thank you chair just blind it
was close uh thank you chair just for
just to answer council Mrs Rowe um the
reason we're not nominating to that
committee uh certainly for a personal
point of view is because I haven't got
the time because my working life to give
it dedication so that's one nomination
to me but thank you
okay could we have a clarification on a
council Mrs Mason's point please
the Second Amendment
German members I'm still getting up to
date so with your Constitution here uh
but it does have to be on Pro router
rules unless you actually vote to make
all committees non-pro rata
foreign
I vaguely recall that in the past it's
I'm sure it happened in Council as well
where a committee May
be non-p an individual committee or just
maybe non-pror so if the vote of the
council is unanimous
and is that what you were saying not all
committees but that one can be unanimous
yes it is exactly that but it has been
unanimous vote
so to clarify if the conservatives
wanted to put someone an additional
person onto that committee and we vote
to unanimously for that
that would be acceptable
is that correct this means that no one
must vote your Gates rather than
everyone must vote for so Mr I'm having
a little difficulty hearing you sorry
I'll go go closer I should be short
enough for it as well
um my understanding that is that if that
happened the vote would be unanimous but
it we ignore non-votes for that it as
long as everyone who votes votes for but
no one votes against is that correct
um
sorry
yes that is correct
Okay so
yeah
does anybody wish to move that
There's an opportunity for somebody to
be put forward through the committee
provided of those that vote it's a
unanimous vote that person can go on the
committee from any side of the training
Council Mr wood
thank you chairman and thank you for
spelling that out so clearly in that
case we would like to nominate Mrs Tony
Carter
council Mrs Rowe
thank you chairman I will second that
councilor Wilkinson you indicated
thank you chair now I was going to you
were looking for someone to move the
motion I was going to move a motion that
we do votes
um unanimously to make that committee
um to offer it to the other group is
what I was going to vote on but
therefore they were ahead of the game so
I'll see you
members
that recommendation is before you
those who are in favor please indicate
lower your hands
those against
I'm not any abstentions
with the extensions that means it's not
carried
it had to be a non-vote
so unfortunately sorry we're still there
I'm difficulty hearing you so I'm
getting nearer now
I understood and that was what I
understood from what was said by the
officer and when I've read the
Constitution that as long as no one
voted against and I thought that was
what was said
can you clarify that
please
give us a moment
episode
good morning train officer
so we had a look at the Constitution
we've also had a look at the legislation
as well and we would like to have her
some time to actually go and have a look
at that to make sure we are doing this
right
so with that in mind uh we're suggesting
that you do nominate the full of ones
that are already there so approve them
and leave that one post and we'll come
back to you in a future date to be
absolutely cool about how we actually go
about filling that post
yeah
may I propose that that item is deferred
to the next meeting thank you
council Mrs Wilson
hello Chad just like to clarify
um what the officer said earlier my
understanding was was that the vote had
to be unanimous
um could I just ask for clarification on
that as well please
cheese
thank you for your question on that
again we'd like to take that away and
have a look at it if we're not actually
going to be voting on this anyway then
we can take it away and make sure that
we are absolutely how to deal with this
on a future date
just to some members know councilor
customer has seconded councilman
McPherson's motion there
um next speaker I've got is councilor Mr
Wilkinson
thank you chair said advice has got my
name written down already
um just clarify is that the entire item
being deferred or just that Committee
just that committee sorry it was just
you the word item was used that was also
it's just that committee thing that
committee
my apologies counselor Wilkinson
proposal is in front of you
those who are
deemed that worthy of
acknowledgment
I'm lost completely those in favor
of the deferment
okay put your hands down please
okay I need to go for those against
none any abstentions
done
so that item is deferred that
committee is deferred thank you
child work
okay
just confirm me that's the end of that
item isn't it yeah okay
right members agenda item 10
designation of strategy roles monitor
officer and section 151 officer
the report will be introduced by the
chief executor chief executive from
Jonathan Stevenson
[Music]
thank you chairman
um
in front of you members you've got item
10 there's an interest actually roles a
mortgage officer and section 151 officer
before I present the report I just
thought I'd like to put a record thank
you in support of Angelo's our previous
monitoring officer and Naomi Lucas as
our 151 officer a big thank you for the
work they've done and undertaken over
the many years supporting the council
and before I move on to the
recommendations report so report
recommends to designate the statutory
roles of monetary officer to Andrew
Hunkin who's our interim director of
people in governance from the 14th of
December 2022 and also to designate the
statute role of section 151 officer to
Tim Willis our interim director of
resources from the 14th of December
2002.
um Tim is here in front of you tonight
and so is that so is Andrew at this
meeting
um recommendations can be found at 8.1
I'm happy to take any questions if
required
members are there any questions
counselor Mr Wilson
thanks chairman I throw you to the chief
executive
um what period of Handover was given and
are you content that that was sufficient
to give continuity of service
thank you chairman um with regard to
Handover obviously um there's two roles
we're talking about tonight um Naomi
Lucas is still with the organization to
the end of this week and um Tim Willis
is working with a Handover and the law
has been providing Handover to Andrew
and she's last days at the end of
December but she's taking some bleed end
of December so she still works for the
council for the end of December and
she's taking some leave between now and
the end of December there's been
adequate Handover obviously
um there is still like any
familiarization in new roles so um
people are learning and developing in
these roles we've got constitution in
front of us tonight I know there's a
number of questions quite difficult
technicality that was discussed tonight
it's obviously um that's why we defer
that rather than make the wrong decision
this evening so um thank you
anyone else Castlewood
[Music]
thank you chairman in respect of 0.3 of
recommendation eight
um can I say that in respect of the last
item I find it quite tedious and quite
embarrassing and actually doesn't show
this Council in the best light to be
discussing voting arrangements and I
would actually ask that that is
clarified so that there is clear
understanding when we come to voting we
go through this process every time we
have votes on committees and I did
rather think in the spirit of Christmas
and I thought that on taunt cordial had
broken out between the various groups
and it would be a fairly straightforward
matter of allocating people to
committees and undoubtedly on this side
there was confusion in the voting and
I'm still not clear that it's been
clarified even in respect of all the
other votes that we've taken this
evening so I think that is an urgent
priority on the Constitution so there is
Clarity and we stop going through this
charade every time there's apportionment
on committees thank you chairman
members any other questions
okay
members there are three recommendations
set out on in paragraph 8.1 of the
report on page 10.2
I'll read them out
Andrew hanking be designated as the
monitoring officer for the council
that Tim Willis be designated as section
151 officer for the council that the
monetary officer make any necessary
subsequent changes to the council's
Constitution
move that from the chair to have a
secondary
thank you councilman this is McPherson
members are you happy for me to take
those items all together
thank you
members those in favor please signify
against sorry lower your hands against
any abstentions
okay that's 29 in favor and four
extensions that is carried
members agenda item 11.
attendance at the Royal Garden Party
2023
the councilor's interim director of
people and governance and ranking will
introduce the report
thank you chairman that is usual for
Rochester District Council to have
either one or two
invites to the Royal Garden parties it
is clear that if there is one then you
have cancer MJ Webb who has the most
service but if there is a second place
to be allocated then you have eight
members who are able to to attend that
and if you when it comes to
recommendations you'll see there's a
recommendation there that we have a we
draw lots to see if uh who will attend
the second
a place if we actually get it and if the
recommendations are passed then the
chairman will draw the laws
are there any questions
okay members
okay the first recommendation we need to
deal with
is the counselor Mr Webb and and guest
be nominated to attend the forthcoming
Royal Garden party invitation
those in favor sorry a second to break
pardon
okay councilor thank you Mrs McPherson
uh those in favor
thank you members that is unanimous
okay second item
is that a random lot be drawn at this
meeting
of the Council on the 13th of December
2022 to determine the second nominee to
attend the forthcoming Royal Garden
Party
invitation in the event of two places
plus guest
being allocated for 2023. I'll move that
from the chair to have a second note
counselor Mrs Mason
did you second that okay thank you
okay members those in favor of
drawing the lot
please indicate
okay lower your hands
those against
any abstentions
okay that is Carrie
members we now do the draw
ER
members the name out of the hatch is
counselor Mill
okay members we have two further
recommendations
the next one is that the Civic officer
submit the nominations to attend the
Royal Garden Party once confirmation of
the
councils allocated allocation is
received from the palace
and the last one that the Civic car and
Civic chauffeur be used to transport the
attendees represented Rochford district
council at the Royal Garden party I'll
move this from the chair to have a
second
thank you Mr Susan
members those in favor
thank you members that is unanimous
members agenda item 12.
reports from the executive and
committees to the council
members we have a report from the audit
committee on the appointment of
independent member to the audit
committee
Jim Willis will interim director of
resources will introduce the report
thank you chairman
um this report proposes that an
independent member is appointed to the
council's audit committee from the start
of the new Municipal year
2023-24 as recommended by central
government following the Redmond review
and in lineman with the chartered
Institute of Public Finance and
accountancy best practice
it's further proposed that the
recruitment of the independent member be
delegated to the director of resources
in consultation with the chairman and
two other members of the audit committee
thank you
any questions members
okay members I'll move that from the
chair who I have a second
councilor Mill
is that second in
counselor Mrs Mason did you indicate
thank you
members are you happy to take those
recommendations together
okay
those in favor
thank you members that's unanimous
members we now have a report from the
overview and scrutiny committee on the
2022 mid-year treasury management review
councilor Mrs McPherson Vice chairman of
the overalls cooking committee will
introduce the report
thank you chairman
um members I'm introduced in the report
tonight only because at the last meet
when this came forward to the overview
in scrutiny it was a very rare occasion
where our chairman was imprisoned so
members this report sets out the
council's treasury management activity
for the first half of the financial year
the report is presented to four Council
in accordance with SIP first code of
practice and treasury management
treasury management relates to cash flow
management and funding the council's
capital plans
the primary objectives are to ensure the
council has adequate cash at all times
being mindful of risk the reference to
risk relates to the need to be sure that
the council maintains adequate liquidity
in simple terms that it can pay all its
bills such as its suppliers and staff it
also relates to Investments no undue
risk should ever be taken when decisions
are made regarding the council's cash is
invested
the council has no external borrowing so
the report is relatively straightforward
as interest rates are rising there is
the prospect of high investment in
returns however the council does not
invest for more than one year in
accordance with its approved policies
this helps protect protect liquidity but
it also limits the investment returns
rochford's overall approach to treasury
management is prudent this is partly
because it is how treasury management
operates in local government
and it is governed by legislation
sorry regulation I should say but it is
also worth noting that councils that
have had a higher risk appetite have
sometimes got into financial difficulty
and this can have a direct impact on the
amount of funding available to invest in
and run services
so the overview and scrutiny committee
fully support the existing policies that
carbon govern our treasury management I
move the contents of the treasury
management media report to be noted by
members thank you thank you chairman
foreign
okay
members the contents of the treasury
management media report be noted
is that noted members
agenda item 13 reported the leader on
from off the leader on the work of the
executive
is that noted members
gender item 10 public questions and
member questions on notice
members we have no public questions but
there are a number of member questions
on notice which we will go through in
turn
ER Missy McPherson can I invite you to
read out your question to the portfolio
holder for communities housing health
and health please
thank you chairman
it was noted at the last council meeting
that our Council
for our Council to actively promote the
rspca's public awareness campaign about
the impact of fireworks on Animal
Welfare and vulnerable people
including the proportions that can be
taken to mitigate risks
could the portfolio holder for Community
please advise what action was taken
Council Williams
yeah thank you I thank you councilor
McPherson Council Williams can you move
the microwave closer please can't get
much closely it's not um
thank you
thank you councilor McPherson I'm
pleased to have the opportunity to speak
about what we are doing regarding this
subject
as we all know guys thoughts
why is it not
try again thank you thank you councilman
McPherson it's good to have the
opportunity to speak about what we are
doing regarding this subject
as we all know gray fox fireworks can be
a nightmare for vulnerable adults young
children family pets and wild animals
that is why this year Rochford District
Council has supported and will continue
to support the rspca firework bang out
of order campaign
a press release was made by RDC
reminding residents of their obligations
regarding the safe and considerate use
of fireworks also the benefits of
attending organized displays these are
also listed on our events page pointing
out the benefits and Times of organized
displays so that pet owners were able to
prepare animals for noises and flashes
also that we fully support the rspca
campaign direct links were also given to
the rspca site in addition to this we
raised awareness of these these issues
on social media Twitter Facebook
the informational links will remain
active on our website until after
Christmas and New Year's period to cover
any Festive Celebrations
I do have copies of air press release
should any members wish to have sight of
this
on a personal note I will like to add
that I will at all points as well
whenever possible I will Lobby to to
have the noise of fireworks reduced
thank you
thank you Council Williams
do you have a supplementary question
I do actually uh chairman thank you very
much
sorry counselor uh Mr Williams
um
Could you um I advise are you
um having conversations for example with
our licensing team about including
um certain
conditions or advice within event
management plans that they work with
large events within our district thank
you chairman
future thank you chairman
um yeah I can confirm that all major
events have to have a temporary event
notice so that you're saying that is the
case thank you
thank you chairman that answers my
question thank you
thank you counselor Williams
uh councilor Foster uh put forward a
question I'm afraid he's not here this
evening so I'll put the question from
councilor Foster on foreign
question is to the leader
Chancellor in November's statement
announced that councils will be allowed
to increase council tax and fly up to
five percent next year
do you have any sense of whether RDC
will need to make that level of increase
councilor Orton
thank you chairman and thank you for
reading out councilor Foster's question
the chancellor made an announcement in
the Autumn statement regarding council
tax increases it was to allow lower tier
councils such as Rochford to increase
council tax in 2023 by up to three
percent without the need for a
referendum
to be clear the five percent threshold
only applies to Upper tier councils such
as the county if the social care precept
is included
ministerial officials have subsequently
advised that the five pound limit also
applies which would mean that Rochford
could increase its council tax by 3 or 5
pounds whichever is the higher without
the need for a referendum
the council tax for a banned D property
currently stands at 245 pounds 16 Pence
so if the percentage rise was applied
next year's increase would be limited in
cash terms to seven pounds 35.
there have been regular all member
budget briefings on the financial
position and the issues the council
faces now and in the future
this Administration and the executive is
still formulating its proposals to
council regarding the
2023-2024 budget and consequential
impact on council tax so it is too early
to go into any detail
at the end of the day the council is no
different to any business facing Rising
prices and exposed to inflationary
pressures from its suppliers
moving forward I do not pretend for one
moment that managing Council finances
and balancing priorities will be an easy
task
none of us in this room came into public
life to do anything other than wanting
to improve the lives of our residents
and businesses and make the Rochford
District a great place in which to live
and work
the conservative Administration has a
long and proud record of fiscal prudence
and producing a balanced budget each
year
it has no borrowing and therefore
without the need of interest in capital
repayments it has no risky lending in
fact no lending at all
furthermore successive audits have
concluded value for Money Services
whilst at the same time there is a clear
evidence of substantial capital
investment in the district
despite the challenges I'm confident
that unlike some councils this strategy
can continue under our Administration
all I would say at the moment is that
the district share of council tax offers
excellent value for money all the
council services are provided to
residents at a cost of less at a cost of
less than five pounds a week for a
banned D property
even if we increased it by the full
amount it would still be at a cost of
less than five pounds a week
of course those households that have
difficulty paying their council tax may
be eligible for a discount on their bill
through the council tax support scheme
thank you Mr chairman
thank you Council organ I've not been
advised by councilor Foster that he had
any form of supplementary question but I
am sure that if he has he will take it
up with you outside of this meeting
okay next one is counselor Constable can
you please read out your question to the
portfolio holder for the environment
probably now
I think you'll have to hold it up
now it's not on
try that
no try the other one
Second Time Lucky following on from the
recent tree planting across the district
what is the work plan for maintaining
the saplings especially if 2023 is
another hot dry year
oh
you look okay
he might pay to hold it up okay that's
true
thank you for the question councilor
Constable which is very logical in view
all of all the efforts that has gone
into planning parts for nature program
not to mention the extra work undertaken
in planting all these whips
however if I may I would like to mention
all the other trees we have or will be
planting in the weeks ahead across the
district and their watering Arrangements
some more standards and also additional
trees in the Orchards a Cherry Orchard
Country Park will be planted
the standard trees that are being
planted are from the Urban Tree
challenge fund and will be watered by
Essex County Council as part of the
funding opportunity and we would expect
that a tractor and Bowser watering
system will be used but we have no
further details are present
the whips we have planted are to be
mulch before spring as part of the
funding from Essex County County and the
Woodland Trust
this will ensure good moisture retention
and should mean that they will not
require watering
our Orchard trees are being planted in
Cherry Ultra Country Park and will be
watered by either our Open Spaces team
and or contractors most likely both if
we have another hot summer like last
year
we are aware that Brentwood Borough
Council has a Bowser and that we trust
we can borrow so you may rest assured
that we will monitor all aspects of the
watering situation closely and take any
action as necessary to ensure the
maximum number of whips and trees
survive survive the initial period
should we have another very hot summer
like last year
we will adopt the same approach to
watering as we did earlier this year
with with the Queen's green canopy in
Cherry Orchard Country Park
thank you chairman
thank you Council Sperry
Cass constable do you have a
supplementary question
it's already been
the chairman thank you cool
okay next question is from councilor
Shaw councilor Shaw can you please read
out your question to the leader
can the leader please advise what work
is being done to help the the pupils
that attend King Edward and King Edwin's
school and what information is being
given being giving to residents living
within the vicinity of the school please
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
council Mrs Shaw for your question
as members will know the king Edmonds
School in Rochford had to be closed due
to the discovery of asbestos during
Department of Education DFE Works to
build a new classroom block at the site
the school had to be closed suddenly on
the 15th of November
students were facing working from home
until the work had been completed
this Council was approached by King
Edmond's school on the 24th of November
when I had a conversation with the head
teacher Mr Osborne
by working together this Council was
able to provide space in The Freight
House for use by teachers and around
approximately 30 pupils
since the 29th of November special
education needs pupils have been having
lessons at the building with remaining
pupils continuing to learn from home
as leader a bit like you a bit earlier
chairman I want to extend my very
sincere thanks to the staff of this
Council and our partners Fusion who
worked extremely hard to prepare and
ensure the space was fit for purpose in
such a tight time frame just two working
days
in a quote from the head teacher Mr
Jonathan Osborne said
on behalf of the school I want to thank
everyone involved in making this happen
we are extremely grateful to Rochford
Council as well as other partners for
the way they have supported us at speed
to meet the needs of our students it
speaks volumes about the commitment of
the council and its officers to the
young people who attend the king Edmonds
School
current conversations with the school
assume that the school will reopen in
the new year
however Essex County Council DFE and the
school will confirm this with their own
Communications
The Freight House however remains
available to the school should they need
to continue to use the site during this
emergency
officers have remained in the close
contact with the head teacher offering
our support
however this issue is being managed by
the health and safety executive so our
role is one of support
the DFE engaged The Specialist asbestos
removal company to conduct a
comprehensive sampling program of the
demolition site and surrounding area all
unschool grounds if these results
indicated an issue the sampling area
would be expanded to include local
Residential Properties
the sampling comprised of 200 samples
including solid core samples taken from
the rubble and air testing to look for
free floating fibers
the air testing included the caretaker's
house that is located on the boundary of
the school near other Residential
Properties
Oracle Solutions have completed their
sampling and subsequently subsequently
confirmed to the DFE that all of the
samples have passed acceptable levels
and that it is safe to remove the rubble
without additional Asbestos safeguards
and the waste material is currently
being removed from site
a full report on the results is expected
shortly and the head teacher has agreed
to share these with the council once
they are issued once officers have the
report it will be reviewed and further
updates provided
as stated the site is enforced by the
health and safety executive from
conversations with them they are happy
with the situation and are not minded to
take action thank you Mr chairman thank
you councilor
do you have any supplementary question
no thank you chairman sure
members that finishes that particular
item item agenda item 15.
motions on notice we have two
first motion is proposed by councilor
Mrs Belton and seconded by councilor hoy
council is Belton would you like to
introduce your motion please
thank you chair
so this motion proposes that Rochford
District Council undertake an initial
one-year air pollution monitoring
program covering schools across the
district we believe that 16 additional
tubes will collect data for 21 schools
subject to the suitability of those
locations being checked in addition we
would like to investigate the
possibility of purchasing a mobile
testing unit or sharing one with another
local authority to allow us to be
reactive when potential sites are raised
testing has to be conducted from January
to December in order to officially
um call the data
and whilst in most cases we hope that
the level will be well within the
national acceptance We Believe print
prevention is better than cure
a budget of only 643 pound 20 is needed
for the tubes for one year based on 16
tubes with the addition of half a day
per month offers a time to collect those
tubes
as part of the initiative a behavioral
change in educational program would be
rolled out to schools in the district
for parents teachers and students
we have evidence from the current
testing sites that proves the reduction
in traffic significantly improves the
quality of air and as such working with
these stakeholders to encourage change
could make a difference that we can
report on and reward or incentivize
it states that we were looking at ten
thousand pound step funding this has now
been approved so we do have that
available to us towards this project
and I would just like to thank councilor
Hoy and the other councilors that took
an active approach with this over the
last six months to shortlist the areas
thank you
Council Mr Hoy can you confirm the U.S
second unit motion
come on secretary can I speak later
please okay
members are there any questions
counselor Newport
thank you chairman
um
firstly I'd like to congratulate
councilor Hoy to get this motion
supported by a conservative member
the lib Dems and Rochford District
residents and the green group sought
additional air quality monitoring in
2016 when the request was dismissed by
the administration
although we personally paid to carry out
our own testing across the district
the administration didn't listen to the
residence concerns
but here we are six years later and
councilor Belton is proposing that the
administration comes round to our way of
thinking which is great
our residents are concerned about air
quality and they know that poor air
quality contributes to many premature
deaths
of course for those living on the
ashington road and the pupils attended
whole Farm school is too little too late
as the hundreds of additional cars on
the new housing will bring that the new
housing will bring will contribute to
even more pollution and the removal of
the tree which just add some insult to
injury for residents and any hope of
improving their air quality
if the administration had acted sooner
then perhaps the data collected would
have been significant
of significant benefit but we will never
know the possible alternative outcome
however looking to the Future
I agree that we need to know if and
where hotspot support air quality are
so proactive approach of action can be
taken and we can potentially save lives
I do however think that we do not need
to lay any more weight on our already
overstretch offices in trying to roll
out an educational program when one is
already in place by Essex County Council
chairman I would therefore like to move
the following amendment to this motion
that paragraph
and I shall uh
try and go through this slowly
but basically what I would like to do
amend the motion by removing
paragraph six chairman which is as part
of the initiative of Behavioral change
to incentivize that paragraph
and simply replace it with
a line that says Rochford District
Council will work with Partners at Essex
County Council to support the
sustainable transport schemes which
includes behavioral change in this
initiatives being rolled out such as
healthy school streets
if do you need me to repeat that
chairman
yes could you repeat that please
councilman newborn so we're clear that
we remove paragraph six
and add Rochford District Council we'll
work with Partners at Essex County
Council to support the sustainable
transport schemes which include
behavioral change initiatives being
rolled out such as healthy
School streets
is that okay chairman
okay thank you Council Newport okay
thank you chairman Do you have a
seconder
okay so Stanley are you second in there
yes chairman thank you okay
members we need to debate the amendment
so are there any questions or comments
on the amendment counselor Constable you
had your hand up first
yes I'd like to speak can you
is that one working now yeah I'd like to
speak against that motion I think
um leaving Essex County Council to deal
with this issue is a little bit backward
thinking I think we could deal with this
far better locally rather than involving
Essex County Council so therefore I
cannot uh support that motion okay thank
you
council Mrs Nelson
thank you um I agree with Council
councilor
councilor concerts and partners I would
like us to be able to leave it open and
roll out an initiative that we support
as a soul that works for our schools and
our residents
councilor Wilkinson
thank you Jack
um I'd like to understand the benefits
that councilor Newports thinks being ECC
involved in this would would do I'd just
like to understand the basis behind his
amendments for me
Council Newport can you answer that
question
yes chairman
um All County members will be aware that
the sustainable transport officer at
Essex County Council is working with
every school in the district or will be
working with every school in the
district to enact their healthy School
Street schemes around the district and
all of those details are available on
Essex County council's website
or alternatively I'm sure councilor Lee
Scott will uh
send out any information required at a
later stage but
there is already work ongoing between
head teachers and it may be a little bit
confusing for hey teachers
um to have Rochford District Council
then come along to try and educate as
well as Essex County Council and I think
resource wise we're just duplicating or
trying to duplicate the work that's
already being done by Essex and being
paid for thank you thank you Paul
councilor Stanley
[Music]
thank you chairman
um I do think that this amendment is
quality in itself and the SEC to council
is in talks with all the schools in the
area that's what assists County Council
is therefore as they can control
everything that goes into the schools
and they'll Converse him with those
schools as we speak thank you
councilor Mrs Mason foreign
I think we're getting booked down into
something that the amendment is focusing
more on who's doing something and rather
than how effective it's going to be at
six County Council is the highway
Authority
but they are the highway Authority for a
very large area
and we all know the difficulties that we
are facing with Highway issues
I don't see any reason why this Council
can't supplement the work that's being
done I'm sure that councilor Belton is
quite capable of liaising with County
Council so that there's no conflict and
that the work that we do is important
for our residents and it's our residents
that we should be focusing on so I'm
afraid I will not be supporting the
amendment thank you
thank you Mr chairman um
I
find it quite surprising that this
agenda was published
of the order of about 10 days ago
and we wait till this evening before
councilor Newport talks to either
councilor Hoyle councilor Mrs Belton
about his proposed amendment
because here we are once again and it
happened last Council where we have a
really decent cross-party motion on the
table and I really would like to see a
greater cross-party working
there's absolutely no reason why we
shouldn't work with Essie's County
Council I'm not for one moment uh
knocking that opportunity but I believe
that already happens uh through other
meetings I'm aware of the work that
transport East is promoting
um but I can't quite see why every time
we well I won't say every time that's
not a fair statement but I can't quite
see why all of a sudden love breaks out
between Essex County councilors and
Rochford District councilors on a motion
which is holy Rochford District Council
coming up with an absolutely Splendid
idea I don't really see why we need to
involve ourselves I've got absolutely
nothing against our working with Essex
County Council but this is a good motion
it stands in its own right on its own
certainly we want to work with Essex
County Council but I see no
justification whatsoever to amend the
wording at the 11th hour I think it's a
good motion and I will be voting against
the amendment
anyone else
okay just before I put that to the vote
can I just confirm with the monitoring
officer as a member of Essex County
Council whether I need to declare a
declare
[Music]
the chairman I don't think there is a
need to declare on this particular issue
thank you
okay
Council Mr Shaw
councilor but I'm also on the vice chair
for Seth
um declare a non-pecuniary interest
thank you
thank you okay any other items on this
amendment
okay members we need to vote on the
amendment
okay uh councilor Hoy did you want to
come back sorry big pardon
drop it again
members you've heard the amendment from
Council Newport those in favor please
indicate
okay thank you members
those against
okay thank you members any abstentions
can I have the numbers
there was six four 23 against three
extension that amendment is lost
thank you members
we now go back to the original motion
does anybody wish to speak or question
on the original motion councilor Mr
Mason
thank you thank you chairman
um a question is about the substance of
the the motion it refers in particular
to NO2 I have first of all concerns
about particulates so I'd like a
confirmation an assurance that
particulates are going to be measured as
well
thank you thank you council Mrs Bell can
you answer that question
I'm not a scientist I'm afraid so I
don't know all the specifics but Council
Hawaii may be able to because this has
been discussed
thank you
councilman Snow White can you come
clarify that question
can you put the like a little closer
please sorry or get used to this
um
particular time not
being measured
separately they can only be measured
through the division tubes which is a
byproduct of actually measuring for
NO2 so
the answer is probably no but the the
initial the additional monitoring unit
that we were talking about within the
motion would monitor
for a particulate matter yes
and I mean if you want to I can talk on
the motion now exactly I've got a couple
of more people want to come in so I can
come on to that in a bit more detail
later then okay thank you okay
council Mrs good in
guys
[Music]
thank you chair
I believe this initiative is most
welcome particularly since concerns were
raised at Holt Farm School
um
this I believe was what kick-started the
committee coming together to talk about
this can the portfolio holder councilor
Belton please give the rationale for the
locations
um
are there any newly proposed or
construction roads will they be included
in the future is that something we can
consider
Castle's bill can you clarify that point
please yeah thank you and the initial 16
in tubes the the way that we came to
these sites was by looking at all of the
schools across the district
cross-referencing existing monitoring
that takes place looking at what schools
could be monitored in Partnership
because of their locations and
essentially working out where they would
need to go to get the best coverage
across all of the schools that includes
all levels of Education senior schools
as well the the mobile unit is so that
we could be reactive and make changes
should new developments new sites come
come up but for the first 12 12 months
it's been proposed that these 16 sites
look suitable working with the relevant
officer he has identified these as as
the best places to get the biggest
capture and multiple counselors were
involved in that to ensure that we got
good coverage across the district at all
levels can you just clarify me from
Council Miss film does that include the
awaker in school it does okay
okay any other points
councilor Mrs Mason
thank you
um I do welcome this I I think it's well
done
councilor Belton would not be have been
aware that this was refused by Rochford
Council in 2016.
um and I set that though Council Hoya
was involved in the
the work that was carried out by the
other groups we did one of the sites
that we monitored was in fact hope Farm
School
and though I believe in councilor
Newport will correct me if I'm wrong
here that all of the areas that we
monitored were within limits and these
were paid for Remember by members
because Rochford refused at that time so
I'm really pleased that this is being
done by the council
um they were close so I think it's well
overdue but what I would like to ask the
portfolio holder to look at in the
future I accept that it's not included
in this motion to look at particulates
because that is very important so
um obviously I have a concern that's not
being included but certainly welcome the
motion thank you
council is Belton if the um if you can
clarify whether it does cover
particulates and let members know that
would be useful perhaps information
later
okay yeah so as Council Ahoy pointed out
the tubes themselves don't don't monitor
particulates in their on their own
that's part of the whole monitoring
um but I think Council Ohio will come on
to this because we did discuss it in our
group meeting some months ago
um the device itself to to record
particulates on their own is extremely
expensive and hard to come by or it was
at that time
um but certainly we'd be open to
improving things in the future and just
enhancing and growing on what we're
intending to do in this initial motion
see any other questions points to raise
okay Council Ahoy would you like to sum
up on that before we put into vote
yes thank you chairman I'd like to thank
um
Council Missy Belton for um
taking this on so enthusiastically after
my email to her in June which I had to
be worked out for a little while but I
realized that after speaking to
councilor Wootton
um about how he wanted to include
everyone in the work of the council I
thought I would try it and I have to say
it's worked very well so far so thank
you
um
I'll be serious for a bit
um so everyone has should have the right
to re to breathe clean air it's fun to
go into Fair health and to our lives of
our children
um
I think this particularly Drew
Drew my attention
with the um
death of a school girl
there's a bill currently
that has been passed by the house of
laws a cleaner air Human Rights bill
known as Ella's law
and it's Ella who made me think about
this a bit more it's about school
children walking to school who are
becoming ill and dying in her case
because of poor air quality dangerous
deathly air quality
and that's what started on it then it
again I think councilor Mrs Gooding
mentioned hope Farm School
when the appeal went through we realized
that the air quality data we had
officially wasn't good enough we didn't
really have enough quality we can
extrapolate from somewhere else
and I think we're extrapolating from the
amberlin for Holt Farm school and that
just isn't good enough
so um I thought we should probably
monitor outside all schools to begin
with and this may be moving on a bit
further later as well hopefully
um
so as you can see the the cost of
monitoring for 16 sites 21 schools is is
fairly minimal in the scheme of the
council's budget around 680 pounds
however within this is where we
mentioned mobile monitoring I had the
Good Fortune to recently bump into a
formal office sir of Rochford who dealt
with air monitoring and I got a lot of
information and
there are now much cheaper ways to
monitor air
mechanically they can be attached to
lamp posts and electric and connected to
the power of the lamp post and these can
be moved fairly easily around the
district and they're much cheaper than
the air monitoring unit we used to have
in right at the top of radio High Street
or the larger mobile Street furniture
style ones so certainly we can start
adding more to this motion and hopefully
throughout the forthcoming year add to
this more
um
with regard to the particulate matter
which Council Mr Mason mentioned and
others
these the ones you attach to lampposts
will monitor
particulate matter
um
and I'll also add that the particulate
matter the sizes may be coming down so
given the recent change in legislation
so particular matter 2.5 maybe come five
from the current 20. but I understand
there's a big problem because we have so
high and dust here
so until we measured it may be that
we're in the danger area
more than we would like to be
I just finished by saying the monitoring
will give us valuable data to feed into
the new local pain and to put any
planning applications leading from that
or the current plane
but as I said lap of data on pollution
was a clear problem in the Law's
development
I hope you're going to support this
motion as the first step to a cleaner
District Council
thank you Council hoy
members that motion is before you
all those in favor please indicate
thank you members that is unanimous
members we have the second motion
uh
which is proposed by councilor Eaves and
secondly by councilor Belden
counselor Eaves can you please introduce
your motive motion on notice
thank you chair
I think it's fair to say that we are all
too aware of the energy crisis not only
in cost and capacity and long-term
viability of current resources
hydrogen is the most abundant element in
the universe
when burned for energy
or used in a fuel cell it only emits
water which means it has the potential
to be a major source of clean energy for
the world
there is much to be said about the
emerging hydrogen power solution
much of the current hydrogen production
is gray or blue
this motion is focused on green hydrogen
which is the only hydrogen production
that is truly green
although in its relative infancy
eye-watering amounts of money are being
poured into research and development of
green hydrogen and significant advances
are being made
the potential for green hydrogen use as
a sustainable power source for the
future is huge
hydrogen could be used in residential
and Commercial settings
for heating which includes appliances
such as furnaces boilers water heaters
gas fireplaces stoves and laundry dryers
in transportation
fuel to sell electric vehicles fcevs
for passenger and Freight transport are
an emerging market that currently
represents a small fraction of global
vehicle fleets compared to internal
combustion engine vehicles and Battery
electric vehicles
however
fcev potential is promising and the
number of Transportation applications is
growing
a 10-point plan for Net Zero transition
was introduced by the government in 2020
backed by 12 billion pounds of
government investment
aiming to create a quarter of a million
green jobs
there are many examples of areas where
green hydrogen is advancing in the UK
to name a few here are some examples
the first major green hydrogen
production and storage plant will be
operational in bath next spring
action plant has been approved to be
built in Hern Bay
where the green hydrogen produced will
be used to power the local buses
Teva a startup company in thurrock is
making the first successful
mass-produced part hydrogen-powered
trucks
local Airlines have a route map in place
for green hydrogen to power commercial
flights in the not too distant future
what this motion is specifically asking
for
knowing the government grants that are
available
is for Rochford District Council to be
looking for companies in our district
that can incorporate green hydrogen into
their businesses
pointing them towards and encouraging
them to take up the not unsubstantial
Government funding that is available
putting the motion into RDC policy will
achieve that aim
the cost to the council for implementing
the motion into policy is none other
than office officers time
but the long-term potential for our
district to bring clean air and
sustainable fuel for the future I
believe is waived heavily in favor of
approving the motion
I sincerely hope that members agree and
vote in favor
thank you Chad
councilor Belton I believe you are a
secondary dick can you confirm and do
you reserve the right to speak at the
end
and yes I can confirm and yes I would
like to reserve the right thank you
members
Council across
thank you chairman
um
councilor Eaves has actually uh stolen
quite a bit of my thunder there I
thought he was just going to read the uh
the items on the agenda but um I just
wanted to speak directly to the motion
and say that I'm 100 behind it for the
following reasons
clearly there is a need to move away
from the use of fossil fuels and other
materials that release harmful
greenhouse gases that contribute towards
global warming
this Council should be excuse the pun
energized to support companies to apply
for funding from government to develop
green hydrogen or very low carbon
hydrogen Technologies
there is currently 240 million pounds
available in the government's Net Zero
hydrogen Fund nzhf in three key areas
initially funding for low-carbon
hydrogen production either by
electrolysis powered by electricity from
renewable sources
the so-called green hydrogen or using
the methane stroke steam process with
carbon capture usage and Storage
the second phase is is looking at
transportation and storage it's not
practical to transport and store in its
natural gas form so it needs to be
liquefied either under high pressure
very high pressure or converted to
liquid ammonia for transportation and
Storage
the usage of hydrogen for flexible
energy combined heat and power
generation heavy industry industrial
processes and transportation as
councilor Eaves mentioned electric buses
heavy Goods Vehicles even ships and
planes
and it was slightly disappointing to
hear that Rochford District Council have
recently replaced their refuse
collection vehicles with diesel-powered
vehicles but I understand the economic
and practical reasons for doing so
there is also additional funding
available now Circa 290 million pounds
to facilitate the switching of fuels
red diesel Etc to hydrogen fuel cell
powered electric vehicles maybe Rochford
district council could look towards this
fund to switch one or more of its new
diesel rcvs to fuel cell electric power
something to consider this would address
0.3 of the motion
uh and just to read from the
government's white paper
um updates of July this year
conclusion last year the UK made clear
its ambition to become a world leader in
the development of a low-carbon hydrogen
economy to help achieve our Net Zero
targets and secure economic benefits
across the UK
since then we have raised our ambition
even further and are now making
extensive progress to realize it with
government and Industry working together
the UK stands firmly at the Forefront of
global efforts to develop low carbon
hydrogen as a clean secure energy source
of the future and to realize the
opportunities it holds for UK businesses
and citizens
so I hope this Council
helps to facilitate this program and I'm
strongly in favor of the motion thank
you chairman
cash rifty
foreign
thank you chairman I'm also in favor of
this motion
um this Council a lot of the officers
members Drive Electric
and my personal opinion I think electric
is going to be a stop Gap if we don't
have something to generate electricity
and hydrogen I think is one of the main
things that's going to be used in the
future so anything we can do to help
with hydrogen and with green energy
is has my support thank you
okay
Council Ahoy is next on my list
thank you chairman
um yeah I'll be supporting this motion I
think probably no one's surprise about
that
um I just got a couple of questions
really one is can we confirmed that
there are no costs to this I assume
there aren't as there are no costs
mentioned so if it costs neutral or just
office of time to some extent
um
also I'm
aware of the issues around green
hydrogen I understand there's been 25
million was that the one Castle
cross-vention 25 million announced today
from the government for green hydrogen
um so there's certainly grants available
um
I've I just wonder how this is going to
be reported back to council is there a
way we can say that it would be reported
back to full Council within a year
perhaps
but do you have any questions thank you
Council Sperry
thank you chairman uh just to reassure
Council cross
we have a constant conversations with
our partners Norse with Rochford
district council with regard to our
waste collection services and street
cleaning
the advantage perhaps of having North
with us is that they deal with probably
about another 30 councils across the
country so we're having an ongoing
conversation about how things are moving
for and using equipment maintaining and
all the rest of bits and pieces whether
it be electric hydrogen so I can
reassure members that these
conversations are ongoing at all times
thank you chairman you
councilor Mr Mason
I think Mr Mason was first
sorry sorry if I've started a
matrimonial one there sorry
[Music]
been user
my own home
Jaylen I'm fully in support of all this
motion
as indeed I was the last one which is on
green and climate issues
um just a few thoughts came to my mind
as councilor Eaves was speaking
electrically powered transport is going
to increase
and frankly it's going to extend the
demand well beyond anything we can
produce by renewable means
it just can't meet it in fact there's
talk about the grid having to raid the
batteries of electrically powered cars
to sustain the use of the country at the
present time
whether that is seen as a solution to a
current troubles I don't know but the
really good news is if when we if we can
put these plants in the right place
couple them with Renewables solar and
wind then actually we can
electrolyze water and produce green
hydrogen on a double double whammy wind
so I'm in full support of it and I do
hope that our local Industries will
I'm sure this motion will be passed I'm
sure I hope our local Industries will
embrace it and get hold of whatever
support they can to introduce it to at
least their vehicles and maybe
domestic heating thank you Jim
councilor Mrs Mason
well I won't deepen my voice
how's the Mr Mason
I'm going to keep it simple
this is another motion
another project where we can put
Rochford District Council in the
Forefront
there is
councilories has given us a very good
summary and we've heard from other
speakers as well
businesses in our area need to be made
aware of the opportunities available to
them and if they are it will benefit the
whole of our community I don't think I
can say anymore because I think it's all
being said so I'll certainly be
supporting this and thank you okay
councilor Ward
thank you chairman
um I as portfolio holder for strategic
planning really do welcome this I want
this introduced into our local planning
as we go can you speak directly into the
microphone thank you
I want this introduced into our local
plan we have other ideas that will mix
in with this very very well biomass and
various other things that we would want
to look at and which we will try to
introduce going along but I really do
welcome this and there was an
interesting part in regards that I found
out in regards to Worcester Worcester
Bosch apparently they are doing a
massive experiment of
gas
and its hydrogen that is being pumped
into Worcester is a major experiment and
it is working very well so it bodes very
well for the future we don't necessarily
need to to Frack or anything like that
we can actually produce hydrogen it'll
be changes there'll obviously be
amendments to boilers but the boilers
can remain the same they can be amended
on the burners so frankly I'm going to
fully support this motion totally agree
with it and once it incorporated into
our strategic planning thank you
Council constable
thank you
um as somebody that has been working in
the gas industry for nearly 50 years now
there is no clean way and cheap way of
producing hydrogen what one of the
methods they spoke about earlier is
burning natural gas to produce another
gas so there isn't a clean way and there
isn't a cheap way of producing hydrogen
when it does come in it will be greatly
appreciated what councilor board was
talking about is the introduction of a
hydrogen mix into the system so if they
introduce 20 hydrogen into the system
then we will save 20 of the carbon
emissions
this country is probably producing less
than one percent of the carbon emissions
emitted in the world
but what little we can do is better than
nothing thank you okay
Council across
yes thank you chairman um I wanted to
move an amendment actually uh to
councilor Eve's motion that is simply to
add a fourth point and Council Ahoy
alluded to it to have
uh so my Amendment would be to have a
regular annual report to the Council on
the progress of the engagements and
funding secured and progressed towards
Rochford District council's own Net Zero
Target by 2030.
okay I've got a note of that
okay can you repeat the wording please
cast across okay uh a fourth point
to have a regular annual report to
Council on the progress of the
engagements
that's with industry potential Partners
Etc and the funding secured and
progressed towards Rochford council's
own Net Zero Target by 2030.
cash crust you have a secondary for that
Amendment
welcome
foreign
can I have a seconder for that
councilor Stanley I think got his hand
up first I think
okay
okay right
Caster Belton do you accept that
amendment to your motion
his amendments and do I still have a
chance to come back at the end yes I
just wanted to say something myself
um members having spent most of my work
in life in the motor trade this is
something that's quite uh intrigued me
over the many years
there is an awful lot of research going
on on companies like JCB
who obviously a digger doesn't work
particularly well on electric power
they are doing a lot of development on
hydrogen internal combustion engines
for farmers and obviously building sites
which also includes a method of
Distributing that gas
um
by different trucks to be able to go out
on the farm
so it's worth actually keeping an eye on
what they are doing as well as they're
doing an awful lot of research on that
as is Mazda with their what was called I
think a lot of memorable members will
remember this is what they refer to as
their Wankel engine which is something
that works far more efficiently on
hydrogen than it does on uh on a petrol
engine
councilor wasn't
thank you Mr chairman I have absolutely
no issue with councilor crosses proposed
amendment except that I want to make
sure that we're not duplicating effort
um I thought that within the carbon
neutral
um
reports the Ambitions that this Council
has to be carbon neutral by 2030 I would
have thought it could be incorporated
within that report but I'd need guidance
from officers as to when that is
actually brought back because I think
it's absolutely right that we do include
it within our reporting but it's very
easy on an evening just to look in silos
and I think there should be a
comprehensive report so in no way didn't
want to diminish that point but I want
to make sure that we're being
comprehensive with our reporting rather
than just having lots of individual
reports thank you chairman
customers Belton
thank you if I may come in first and
then I'm sure Marcus may want to come in
after and add some some value
um what what I would say is that so as
portfolio holder we we meet regularly
and we look at all the strategy and we
we put that together and we constantly
review everything that's going on and
there's a huge amount going on under the
climate umbrella and as you are all
aware we're currently putting together
the strategy the climate strategy that
will come forward to ons before coming
to full Council I absolutely agree that
it needs to be reported on
um what I will say is that some of this
a large part of this motion doesn't
relate to the council's own carbon
neutral strategy it relates to a carbon
neutral strategy for the district and
for looking at how the district improves
so we need to be careful about what our
expectations are because this this
motion is about
incentivizing businesses and Industry
within our district and not the actual
carbon stuff that we have within our own
operations it's our side of that control
I'm open to suggestion as to how we
report but I think it's important that
we can see that positive steps are being
taken and that businesses and Industry
are engaging where the opportunity
arises
okay did the officers come in on that at
all
thank you just to uh to sort of answer
Council Wilson's uh sort of a sort of a
question so I think in many ways the the
motion
um is alluded to in the strategy that's
coming forward but I think he's explicit
what councilor Eaves has put forward in
so many ways I think to ensure that uh
that that ease actually picks up and I
think the motion uh does have Merit in
that it goes beyond what the strategy
says so all those strategies sort of
makes reference to having sort of calm
reduction in terms of
um our vehicle fleets and district-wide
um sort of strategy for for transport
that there's nothing explicitly
um reference to hydrogen in such detail
so the motion has a separate level of
Merit in that sense but as as Council
bill has already said we are taking the
new strategy back into all the reviews
strategy back into overview in the
scripts in January reviews taken to
council and I imagine that the reporting
cycle he picks up with that annually as
well
any other members
councilories
um I can ask you to summarize uh your
motion and obviously in this case add in
the fourth point if you could officers
can help you out if you've lost already
okay thank you chair just before I do
that I would like to just answer one
question that councilor Hoy put forward
on cost I did phone uh Marcus this
morning and just check on the issue of
costs there are no costs involved other
than officer time and I did confirm that
this morning
so the motion is for this Council
commits to identify encourage and engage
Industries in the district to Foster
opportunities towards the development
and implementation of green hydrogen as
a future way of fueling but not limited
to the transport sector
to engage with local companies to learn
from projects in the UK that are either
currently underway or have plans in the
future to power vehicles on green
hydrogen with the view to seeking and
securing any future available funding
for this sector
three to recognize the implementation of
a green hydrogen project will improve
the council's objective of meeting its
carbon neutral targets
and four
to report back to Council on an annual
basis on progress
thank you Council Blues thank you
councilor Mrs Belton do you want to just
add anything to that and then we'll go
to the vote thank you um just just a
couple of things firstly my extensive
thanks to councilor Eaves for doing a
huge amount of research and work in
bringing this motion forward I know a
lot of time and effort has gone into
this and an awful lot of detail has been
presented to us this evening so on
behalf of members I'd like to thank you
and certainly on behalf of myself as
primer and portfolio and and just for
for members some reassurance that we do
have mechanisms for getting this
information out we have Reba we have the
tell me more bulletins that go out and
we have a fantastic economic development
team all of which can do the work to get
this information about grants into the
inboxes and into the ears of those that
need it across the district so I think
we can take positive steps forward to
ensure this isn't a loose motion and
that actually we can get some some
weight behind it with the the teams that
we have
um
and lastly that of course I would like
members to support any motion that comes
forward that further further strengthens
the work that is going on in this
Council cross party to reduce our own
carbon emissions and carbon emissions of
that in the district
um I think there's some really good work
and some good research going on and
again my thanks to to councilor AIDS and
and we look forward to hearing more
detail in in good time from from
councilors on this matter
thank you
okay members that motion is before you
those who are in favor please signify
thank you members
I'm pleased to say that is unanimous
thank you
members just before
did you vote on that okay apologies it's
not unanimous big problem
so did you wish to vote against or
abstain
state
so let me just correct that for the
record what was the numbers then please
thirty two four one abstention councilor
Wooten
I'm just a little unclear as to where
councilor crosses
um Amendment to the motion fits in
because I think that was an extremely
important Point yeah the council crosses
amendment was accepted by the proposer
of the original motion and seconded so
it was added to the original motion
okay
thank you members just before I close
the meeting just to remind you there is
some wine orange juice
water if you wish and some nibbles and
mince pies upstairs I believe so please
feel free to join us and obviously
officers as well you're more than
welcome to join us members are closed
the meeting I make it at 9 45.
[Music]